some guns my next guest has strong words
for me says I'm off the rails on guns in
America ben shapiro is editor at large
at breitbart.com and you're through
bullies our less culture of fear and
intimidation silences America so why am
i off the rails mr. Shapiro you know
honestly Pierce you've kind of been a
bully on this issue because what you do
and I've seen it repeatedly on your show
i watch your show and I've seen it
repeatedly what you tend to do is you
tend to demonize people who differ from
you politically by standing on the
graves of the children of Sandy Hook
saying they don't seem to care enough
about the dead kids if they cared more
about the dead kids they would agree
with you on policy I think we can have a
rational political conversation about
balancing rights and risks and rewards
of all of these different policies but I
don't think that what we need to do is
demonize people on the other side as
being unfeeling about that about what
happened it's yeah you accuse me of
standing on the graves the children that
died that day I've seen you do it
repeatedly piers like I say how dare you
I mean you can keep saying now but
you've done it repeatedly what you do
and I've seen you do it on the program
is you keep saying to folks that if they
disagree with you politically then
somehow this is a violation of what
happened in Sandy Hook and you have yet
I really like to hear your policy
prescriptions for what we should do
about guns because you say that you
respect the Second Amendment and you
know I brought this here for you so you
can read it it's the Constitution and I
would really like for you to explain to
me what you would do about guns that
would have prevented what happened in
Sandy Hook if you want to do what you
did in the UK right which is banned
virtually all guns that is at least a
fair argument and we can have a
discussion about whether that's
something that we are to do and it very
clear what I want to do which is exactly
what Mark Kelly wants to do and if that
rather than address rather than address
your comments to me about standing on
the graves of children at Sandy Hook you
can address them to Mark Kelly because
he agrees with everything that I've been
saying because he feels the same way as
does his wife the gun owners they both
respect the Second Amendment of the
Constitution they don't want to take
away anybody's right to defend
themselves with guns certain types of
dance I don't want to take away assault
weapons which are capable with magazines
that we saw at Aurora and Sandy Hook of
unleashing a ridiculous amount of
because I've seen you I've seen you talk
about assault weapons a lot and I've
seen Mark Kelly talk about assault
weapons the vast majority of murders in
this country that are committed with
they're not committed with assault
weapons they're committed with handguns
so are you willing to ban handguns in
this country that's not what I'm asking
for why not let me ask you don't you
care about the kids who are being killed
in Chicago as much as the kids in Sandy
Hook yes sir then why don't you care
about care about banning the handguns in
Chicago no we'll come to that let me ask
you this let me ask you this what was
the weapon used in Aurora in the movie
theater it was in yeah it was it was an
assault rifle sure okay what was the
weapon used in the Oregon shopping mall
I believe he's an assault rifle correct
what was the weapon used to Sandy Hook
is an assault rifle what was the weapon
used the incident around Christmas when
they find on the loot no to their deaths
in New York State Farm and BART
illegally that was it that was near that
was an assault rifle so the last four
mass shootings in America were all this
all right and the vast is a reason mr.
Shapiro and you can smirk at me and you
can laugh of its working and you can
accuse me of standing on the graves of
dead children yes that is the reason
that people like me and Mark Kelly and
Gabrielle Giffords want to have assault
weapons like that removed from civilian
hands doesn't really justify the the
rationale for why you want to ban
assault weapons why we remove the
preferred weapon of choice these killing
machines well I would like you to range
on ma'am all I'm asking is for you to be
philosophically consistent if what
you're worried about is the removal of
killing machines from the hands and
deranged young people then maybe we
should talk about a blanket gun ban and
let's get to what the left really wants
here and the you know you say that
you're still right because in Britain
this never is about left to right this
issue why is it here well you know we
can talk about Britain in a second I
think the reason that it's about left
and right here is because fundamentally
the right believes that the basis for
the second amendment and they believe in
the Second Amendment the basis for the
second amendment is not really about
self-defense and it's not about hunting
it is about resistance to government
tyranny that's what the founders said
and that's what the right believes in
this country are you fearing so I feared
the possibility of a tyranny rising in
this country in the next 50 to 100 years
let me tell you something cares the fact
that my grandparents and
great-grandparents in Europe didn't fear
that is why they are now ashes in Europe
so this is this kind of leftist
revisionist history where there's never
any fear of democracy going usurpation
or tyrannical is just a decision so to
clarify your position then the answer to
Sandy Hook as it was to Aurora as it was
to Gabrielle givers as it was to
Columbine
to take is you do nothing is that your
position and that's not my position I
actually my position is that we have to
calibrate laws that are designed to get
hands guns out of the hands of bad
people and keep guns in the hands of
good people who want to buy them well I
think one of the ways that you do that
is by better screening for mental
illness I think that you do better
background checks was Adam Lanza's
mother a good person I don't know
whether she was a good person or a bad
person who's responsible with her guns
has there been any evidence to suggest
she was not a good person
no but there's been a serious wait a
minute
by your criteria of the good people
should be allowed the guns and the bad
people shouldn't she would have been
allowed the guns using irresponsible
person she didn't keep her guns locked
up and then that should be against you
you have a mentally ill person in your
house we're talking about laws that we
can both agree on shoes and why or
disagree when she becomes a bad person
well no it's not a matter of
it's not a matter of morally good she
good old body right there's a sheriff
said responsible versus you're
responsible that's correct okay so she
goes from good to bad no she goes from
responsible to irresponsible let's take
a break let's come back and talk more
about this so we don't agree
[Music]
I mean I've been Shapiro editor-at-large
breitbart.com and the author of bullies
do you believe that if you had an
assault weapon ban statistics prove that
you could dry up the supply these guns
I'm less accessible to criminals um I
don't know whether you could make them
less accessible to criminals let's
assume that's the case that you could
make them less accessible to criminals
again my question remains free appears
and I'm still waiting for an answer from
the left on this they say they're
pro-second amendment why don't you want
to ban handguns if you really want to
solve the quote-unquote gun violence
problem in America go after all the guns
why just stop yourself at assault rifles
because I believe and respect an
American's right under the Second
Amendment of the Constitution that you
kindly brought in to defend themselves
with a handgun or a pistol what I don't
understand most murders are committed
with those weapon what I don't know as
we just establish I talked you through
them the last for mass shootings in
America he hadn't had the assault rifle
use them as you know and if he hadn't he
and how the assault rifle he wouldn't
have used them explain to me this I
can't buy this this is six packets of
sudafed one of the many companies that
make this particular ingredient which
you can't buy legally in America there
are six packets that is illegal for me
to buy in that quantity in Walmart say
but I can buy an ar-15 military-style
assault rifle I can you then as we saw
with Holmes the shooter in Aurora going
in six thousand rounds of ammunition
from the internet and I can go and blow
up a movie theater do you think that's
right well we can talk drug laws another
time but does that make sense to you
know I think that why I think what would
make sense is laws that are calibrated
to solve the problem so if you think
that the problem is the only assault
rifles would you remove I would I think
the ones that have largely been removed
from the market fully automatic weapons
would be it would be a good start I
think that you wouldn't remove any
semi-automatic of the tool and no
because semi-automatic just means that
when you pull the trigger runs one
bullet comes out you understand how they
are fifteen performance when it's been
modified and as a magazine in the North
Hollywood shootout you know what it was
illegal to do that and people did it
anyway we have we have 12 million
illegal immigrants in this country we're
not able to stop people people from
coming illegally into this country over
the southern
in two places like California where I
live normally I think you'd be very
hard-pressed she stopped guns from
coming across that border illegally as
well I mean California has some of the
strictest 15 I know not every American
who would you stop I would stop anyone
with a criminal background I would stop
anybody with a history of mental illness
and I would stop and I would ask it and
not ask I would require that people who
have somebody who has a criminal
background or a history of mental
illness in a household keep that gun
locked up and safe what about the
background checks forty percent of all
gun sales in America now gun trades are
not covered by background I believe in
background checks for everybody for
everybody so there should be a database
a national register if it's not public I
don't I don't like what happened with
the journal news putting out gun permits
which allows criminals to target
particular homes when the NRA came out
today after their meeting of the White
House and just said we're just not
prepared to entertain effectively any
kind of new gun restrictions you know if
you think about what's astonishing to me
is the Left attack on the NRA because
the NRA is they don't receive a dime of
public dollars they're not there they're
an interest group I don't see you know
it's funny the left they like to talk
also about violent video games example
framing is left or right because they
have a wholesome the race I'm gonna vote
either way you tend to be more to the
left understand I'll raise you know are
very active and well-funded and powerful
body and what they very quick I promise
the the point that I'm making is this
there's a lot of been been a lot of talk
by a lot of people about video game
violence I haven't seen David Gregory
interviewing the head of the ACLU and
saying it's your broad interpretation of
the First Amendment that's responsible
for this but people are bringing on the
NRA and saying it's your broad
interpretation of the Second Amendment
that's responsible for this they're an
interest group if you want legislation
passed talk to legislators don't go to
Louisiana remember here's what the NRA
and people like Alex Jones and others do
don't let me in with Alex Jones fine
after each of these massacres they come
out all the gun rights supporters come
up very strongly and very vociferous in
their offense and they basically instill
fear they say if every one of the
millions there if everyone in the movie
theater had been armed everyone at the
school had been armed it wouldn't have
happened and here's what happens gun
sales and ammunition sales rocket as
we've seen in the last three weeks I
don't pass the buck tears I mean the
truth is that the reasons don't happen
the reason that people are buying a lot
of gun
right now piers is because people on the
left are talking very much about banning
guns and so a lot of people are saying
if I can't if I'm not gonna have the
right to buy a purchase a weapon of my
choosing in two months I'm gonna go and
buy it now this is very clear like you
want these assault weapons removed you
know I don't know why Ronald Reagan one
of these right he's no God I don't agree
with him on everything did you agree
with the also believed in the
progressive tax rate I don't believe in
that did you agree about salt weapons it
if they believe what you're saying sure
I don't believe I don't know what his
position on the saw weapons was lying
let me read the letter and show this is
letter that he penned along with
President Ford and Carter in 1994 to
Congress while we recognize that assault
webbernet cessation will not stop all
assault weapon crime statistics prove
that we can dry out the supply of these
guns making them less accessible to
criminals we urge you to listen to the
American public and to the law
enforcement community and support a ban
on the further manufacture of these
weapons that was Ronald Reagan okay so
now you can disagree with Ronald Reagan
you keep framing for the left right but
one of the great right-wing presidents
of modern times agreed with me so so
it's not left or right is it no I mean
it appears a way that the NRA through
the 80s and 90s and this law there's a
breakdown of left and right literally
truly respond to this as a left-wing
attack on the American Constitution and
the Second Amendment exactly what you
try to do you come in you brandish your
little book as if I don't know my little
book that's the Constitution United
States our family I know you're seeing
your constitute do you realize I've been
debating this for a very long time then
you show me the Second Amendment yeah I
know the Second Amendment what I haven't
heard is one coherent reason why any
civilian in America needs an ar-15
military-style assault weapon tell me
why you need one I told you why why the
general population of America
law-abiding citizens they need them for
the prospective possibility of
resistance to tyranny which is not a
concern today it may not be a concern to
us but it's guaranteed to come from it
could come from the United States
because governments have gone too
radical before peers it's not how absurd
you sound yeah here's where you go into
the absurd and the bullying you're
absurd you're stupid I understand you
came in here and accused you of standing
on the graves of dead children because
there's one reason
that bullying punching noises heartily
you know what I call it step punching
back twice as hard in the president so
that's what I call bullying what's
astonishing about it is that for weeks
now you have been saying that anybody
who disagrees with your position is
absurd idiotic and doesn't care about
the dead kids in Sandy Hook and then
when I say that that's a bully tactic
you turn around and say I'm bullying you
for saying that it's absurd it's
ridiculous let me ask you again what is
the point of a civilian having an ar-15
assault weapon the point of a civilian
having an ar-15 assault weapon
many of them are ex-military right I
mean I have military friends and I have
no product I don't have a prom with
colon Powell owning an ar-15 assault
weapon it depends on the civilian if
it's a criminal they shouldn't don't
forget criminals are mentally average or
is mentally ill why do they need one to
protect against the possibility of
eventual government tyranny this was the
purpose of the Second Amendment
originally it remains the purpose of the
Second Amendment now and pretending that
governments have never gone usurpation
government is gonna turn on you in a way
that you require I mean that's really
all 15 to challenge them you really
believe in I mean that's for not my
children but the fact is this history is
replete with democracy's going to
radical it has happened it happened in
France in the 19th century it happened
in Spain in the last century it happened
in Germany it happened in Italy Japan
the reason we cannot remove ar-15
assault weapons is because the threat of
your own government turning on you in a
tyrannical way it is because there are
countervailing rights and
responsibilities and without reasonable
law without the issue you have made your
point crystal-clear
people aren't stupid they can make up
their own lines ben shapiro thank